dans ce contexte
nous avons la gendarmerie de sous-préfet
moi-même je crois accorder une attention
immédiate et requise au maire et à
l'incendie dont il a été victime qui
nécessitait notre soutien à la fois
institutionnel et personnel et nous
avons témoigné de jour même par le
sous-préfet le matin et moi-même
l'après-midi ce soutient il me
paraissait important
de vous donner ces éléments de contexte
ou malgré la charge croissante de la
gestion de rendre de l'ordre public je
ne crois pas que l'État est oubliée de
soutenir et d'accompagner un maire
lâchement ciblé par un incendie dans
l'origine criminelle a été confirmée et
encore moins ne pas avoir pris ces
éléments au sérieux les gendarmes ont
d'ailleurs pris sans délai les mesures
de protection
renforcées au bénéfice de Monsieur le
Maire après l'incendie criminel j'y
reviendrai dans quelques instants
sur l'accompagnement du projet au long
cours de ce dossier qui n'a pas pu
empêcher le départ de Monsieur le Maire
puisque nous ne pouvons que constater
qu'il s'est senti obligé de donner sa
démission le sous-préfet apportera
également tous les éléments de détails
dont nous devons vous rendre compte
cette démission est évidemment un
événement grave et elle interpelle à
partir du moment où un élu de la
République estime ne plus être en
situation d'exercer le mandat qui lui a
été confié à cause de pression
d'intimidation ou de menaces accentuées
par une récupération politique de
l'extrême droite et des mouvements
nationaux pression venant de l'extérieur
de la commune porté sur le maire sur les
clips municipales mais également qui
rejaillit sur la population de
Saint-Brevin et la population de
migrants qui est accueillie depuis
plusieurs années au sein de la structure
gérée par notre opérateur
je veux d'ailleurs le V ici un
malentendu ou une incompréhension qui a
pu aboutir à me prêter des propos qui ne
correspondent pas précisément à ceux que
j'ai tenu lors du point presse que j'ai
fait le 11 mai 2023 après que le maire
m'a envoyé son courrier de démission et
qui seront qui sont reproduits notamment
dans une dépêche AFP de la même date que
je tiens à votre disposition
je n'ai jamais affirmé avoir eu
régulièrement ou de nombreuses fois le
maire au téléphone parce que ce n'est
pas le cas en effet j'ai indiqué à la
presse que je l'avais eu le 10 mai au
téléphone à la réception de son courrier
et lui avait renouvelé mon soutien comme
je l'avais fait à plusieurs reprises
devives voix d'abord directement à deux
reprises le 22 mars et donc le 10 mai et
bien mon secrétaire général qu'il l'a
appelé en mon nom et à m'a demandé
Express le 4 avril pour lui réaffirmer
mon soutien et lui indiquer que nous
allions organiser une audience avec le
collectif anti-cadin pour honorer
l'engagement que Monsieur le Maire avait
pris ce qui a été fait le 26 avril en
concertation avec son cabinet
soutien témoigner ensuite par les
consignes que j'ai données
personnellement de ne pas laisser isoler
la commune son maire et l'équipe
municipale lors des deux manifestations
hostiles à l'implantation du CADA celle
du 25 février et celle du 29 avril
d'abord en mobilisant un dispositif de
forte intensité en termes de moyens
d'ordre public qui dépasse le cadre
commun pour des manifestations
réunissant moins de 2000 personnes mais
la récupération par l'extrême droite
dépassait il est vrai également le cadre
de la commune mais surtout et au-delà
des forces c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai décidé la présence d'un sous-préfet
physiquement sur place et d'un officier
général de gendarmerie aux côtés de
l'élu présent pour bien marquer ce
soutien et cette accompagnement